good morning John a couple of weeks ago
tumblr changed how it displays reblogs
and i did not like this because it was
changed and i was frustrated and then
last week I went to Yellowstone National
Park potentially the coolest place on
earth it was the first national park
ever created and it's one of the most
dangerous things on the planet not like
two individuals travelling in the park
though that can be dangerous too I mean
to the whole world really part of the
reason Yellowstone is so interesting is
that it is a very very big volcano three
times in the last two million years the
Yellowstone supervolcano has erupted
spewing out to tens or even hundreds of
cubic miles of debris affecting global
weather patterns and laying ash down as
far away as Texas now this isn't gonna
happen again anytime soon but it will
happen again someday and when it happens
the park will basically be gone but the
remarkable thing is that it happened
600,000 years ago and as you travel the
park you drive over the rim of the
caldera formed in that eruption and
other than that the desolation that
eruption caused is pretty much invisible
life just rushed back in to fill the
void created by that massive event the
ground is a thing that doesn't move if
you're grounded you're like a rock
people change the things we make change
but the land remains the same and yet it
doesn't in Yellowstone more than
anywhere places do not stay the same
geysers turn on and off new Springs eat
through the ground as the water cools
crystals are deposited building into
giant mounds and the ground itself rises
and falls in ripples and domes across
the land as hot gas and magma surges
beneath the surface everything constant
is a lie and my life continues to remind
me of that we want stability but we
can't have it and that's both sad and
wonderful now we apply false stability
to Yellowstone its most famous landmark
of course is Old Faithful a geyser that
blasts every 70 minutes or so with
remarkable regularity but Old Faithful
will one day cheat on us and everyone
knows that someday all of the benches
and lodges we built around it will just
be a semicircle around a bunch of dry
rocks here's new blue spring now dormant
and white
and this is constant geyser so named
because it never stopped spurting until
it did but Yellowstone has broken no
contract with us
it makes no pretense of stability it's
honest in a way the rest of the earth
and even life isn't an honesty that
reminds me that the inevitability of
change though it terrifies me also
excites me that incurable illness that
makes me always want to know what's next
to see the future the future where
things are not like they are today the
future that will allow me to look back
and miss what once was that will scrub
my present day of the din genus and the
crud until I only remember the brilliant
sparkles and the deepest gashes we're
all standing on that cliff beyond which
there is nothing until there is and we
always believe that it will be there
especially those of us who have been so
rarely burned until some day it isn't
there and your life has changed your
world has changed and there's nothing
you can do to get it back again
Yellowstone doesn't lie to me
Yellowstone reminds me that even
something as constant as the ground
beneath my feet could just one day fly
into the air and land in Texas and so
maybe the way my reblogs look on tumblr
isn't the thing I should be worrying
about John I'll see you on Tuesday we've
been in a really long traffic jam we
don't know what we've been in a traffic
jam for and win this minivan moves we
will find out what is it it's a bison
light it's a bison there it is goodbye
it was nice to meet you